what's going on guys this is rob and i
just finished episode 6 of obi-wan
kenobi and and i loved it right we'll
talk about that here in a second but
there is one big thing
that sticks out to me
and that's the whole thing with princess
leia now i get
that obi-wan kenobi told which by the
way spoilers yeah obviously i get that
obi-wan kenobi told her
you can't tell anybody about this
otherwise it'll jeopardize us both
and sure that makes sense when you're 10
and you're like okay so like the
empire's out there stuff's going on so
on and so forth but as you get older you
learn about a thing called wisdom and
you learn to discern the difference
between telling somebody something and
being in like immediate death or just
waiting until a better time to do it and
i kind of feel like this is not really
something you forget as you get older
it's not like she sat down and just had
an amazing meal and then by the time
she's in her 30s or 40s she just forgets
you know and it's like i had a really
good meal once but i don't remember what
it was i feel like this is one of those
things
where you would think somewhere along
the line
after finding out that luke skywalker is
a jedi
and he's her brother
and he was trained by obi-wan kenobi
kind of but not really and really more
trained by yoda but like obi-wan kenobi
was an important figure in his life
you'd think somewhere along the line
she'd be like you know what luke i
remember there was a time when i hung
out with obi-wan kenobi when i was 10
and i was kidnapped
and taken to a different world and then
rescued by obi-wan
and then eventually like
i kind of met darth vader but not really
the empire was trying to kill us i met a
dark jedi
almost died on several occasions
i mean this is
this is not something you forget
it's not one of these things where as
the years go by the memories just begin
to fade no this is kind of a big deal
and so you'd think she would have
brought it up either that or even when
she was older
and the empire was basically defeated
even though you had the first order
which was not nearly as cool as the
empire was
and her son was a jedi at the peak of
his power
she still didn't think it was safe to
tell him
i don't know i don't i don't i don't
know that's the risk you take when you
tell stories like this
involving characters that turn out to be
wildly significant that's just that's
just kind of how it goes so i don't know
how you make that make sense i don't
know how you explain why she never
brought it up
i don't i don't know how you square that
circle having said that that's really
the only thing that stood out to me that
and how riva survived because i don't
think we ever get an explanation i think
she's just there and it's like okay so i
guess she faked her death again and i
guess darth vader just didn't figure it
out this time like he legitimately
believed she was dead even though he
obviously knew she was alive when she
was faking dead among all those people i
don't know i don't know i mean there's
there's obviously some plot holes in
this episode having said that everything
else about it i i absolutely love and
and honestly it was just the darth vader
stuff that i dug right and here's the
thing i feel like what they did with
darth vader in this show gave him more
development than any other depiction of
darth vader really outside of like
return of the jedi and here's the reason
why i said i know it's going to be a
super controversial statement but here's
the reason why i say that one it's only
predicated on episodes one two and three
right one two and three were basically
the story of anakin falling to the dark
side and all that kind of stuff right i
know that that darth vader as he
appeared in episodes four five and six
hold like a special place in like the
star wars phantom's heart and i know
that like they don't want to hear me say
that i think this was better character
development than anything we got in four
five and six but i don't know what to
tell you right that sounds like a you
problem not a me problem so here's the
thing when it came to this version when
it came to how he was depicted here in
that final fight between vader and and
obi-wan kenobi that was amazing because
historically speaking whenever we saw
darth vader specifically in episodes
four five and six and even during like
what was it uh the was it rebels i think
star wars rebels he showed up in i don't
think it was clone wars because he was
anakin during clone wars but the the way
that he was depicted right it was always
just kind of like this just real like a
guy who quite literally lived up to the
statement of obi-wan kenobi when he was
talking to luke that he's more machine
than man twisted and evil and not even
so far that he was evil the fact that he
was just so detached from everything he
had no real emotion at all right he was
just removed he was just a guy that was
there and doing stuff that basically
benefited the empire and furthered their
agenda but for you know like if you look
at him he really does feel like a robot
in a lot of ways he does have emotion in
terms of the inflection of his voice
right when when james earl jones is
voicing and all that kind of stuff you
do get inflection there so obviously
it's a person talking but for the most
part until you get to like
empire strikes back the fact that he
learns that luke is a son even then it's
not a whole lot of emotion and that kind
of stuff by the time you get to the end
of return of the jedi when he turns to
the light side that's when you really
start to get the emotional side of
anakin skywalker what you had here was
great because it's the same thing that
i've been saying this really shows us
that like anakin has not really become
darth vader yet he hasn't become the
darth vader that we know he's still very
much anakin skywalker even if he says
like you know anakin's dead i'm the one
who killed him yada yada setting up the
whole explanation for you know obi-wan
kenobi to luke skywalker you know anakin
skywalker was a really good friend of
mine until he was killed by darth vader
and then he killed a whole bunch of
younglings and then went on a rampage
and started killing all the jedi that he
could that weren't killed in order 66
and all that kind of crazy stuff because
one of the things you guys may not know
and i don't know if this is in
continuity or not although i feel like
it is order 66 did not kill all the jedi
right like there were a lot of jedi who
survived and darth vader actually
started hunting them down which was
really really cool i don't remember if
it's a comic or not if it is i
absolutely want to cover it but i feel
like that might not necessarily be in
continuity although it wouldn't make it
difficult to throw it in there but the
thing about it is in this fight with
obi-wan kenobi like he's still anakin in
every in virtually every way and i gotta
i just gotta throw it out there how
amazing did it look when like when when
obi-wan kenobi like slashes helmet and
you have like this split design where
you've got darth vader on one side and
anakin on the other and it's kind of
interesting because you can look at it
in different ways right you can see it
as like the contrast between anakin
skywalker and who he becomes darth vader
but the reality here is i don't think it
was designed to be a contrast at all i
think it was designed to really just
highlight how far anakin skywalker had
fallen and that anakin really just is
darth vader inside and out like there's
no more anakin anymore right there's no
pulling him back to the light side or
anything like that like as far as
obi-wan is concerned this guy really is
just a lost cause and i thought it was
really really interesting because as i
was looking at that it was like you
would think the bond between obi-wan
kenobi and in anakin was about as strong
of a bond as it could get by the bond
between father and son but the irony of
that is it is a father and son bond that
brings anakin skywalker back to the
light side but it's the father and son
bond between anakin and luke and that i
thought was just a great juxtaposition
there right that obi-wan kenobi was very
much a father figure for anakin but
there was nothing he could do to save
him however luke is the son of anakin
and anakin didn't want to see his son
fall to the dark side the same way he
did so he brings him back right learning
from his own mistakes right saves them
from killing the emperor right it's one
of the big fan theories out there that
when in that scene in return of the jedi
when uh when the emperor tells like
literally tells luke you know take your
lightsaber and strike me down when luke
goes for it and darth vader blocks the
shot it's designed to keep luke from
falling to the dark side right because
if luke killed the emperor he would have
started falling down the path of the
dark side literally that was the first
thing that darth vader did on this path
to save his son of course eventually
trying to kill the emperor or at least
presumably at the time killing the
emperor and then telling his son you
know tell your sister you were writing
all that kind of stuff but nonetheless i
loved i love this moment to me it wasn't
really the duels between darth vader and
obi-wan kenobi although those were cool
it wasn't really the duels necessarily
that i loved so much it was just the
nature of the characters and the fact
that darth vader was still anakin in
some capacity in fact that runs all the
way up until the very end right when you
have him sitting at mustafar on his on
his little fortress and he's talking to
the emperor and it's like we're gonna do
everything we can to hunt this guy down
we're going to find this guy we're going
to kill him but we're going to destroy
obi-wan kenobi just so encompassed by
emotion and rage so caught up about like
capturing obi-wan kind of like this itch
that he can't scratch and so when the
emperor chimes in the emperor is like i
mean you're pretty emotional bro like
like you're you're pretty caught up in
this and of course that's when anakin
basically backs off and is like i only
serve the emperor and so that's that's
the kind of thing where it's like that's
when darth vader just seems to fully
take hold and he fully becomes the darth
vader that we know where he only serves
the emperor and that's basically it but
that emotional side of him right that
human side of him never fully goes away
hence the connection that he had with
luke skywalker if anything he just kind
of hit it well now in the comics there's
a lot of explanation there right in the
comics like you if you ever go back and
read those and we're covering them on
comics explained right now in the comics
that part of darth vader never goes away
right like there's a point where he
doesn't trust the explanation that the
emperor gave him and saying that like
you know he had basically killed padme
so he goes and hunts for for like
padme's body how she died and that kind
of stuff like goes on this kind of
personal journey deviating away from his
own quest and the emperor does stuff to
try to bring him back but at the end of
the day that part of anakin never
disappears but i love that whole thing
right i love that this was kind of this
this series was sort of the the tail end
right kind of wrapping up that plot
thread of how far gone is anakin
skywalker right like when does anak
skywalker fully become darth vader as we
know him again i dug it i i thought it
was really really cool having said all
of that for the character of riva
looking at the show in its entirety and
kind of looking at it in in hindsight i
loved the character of riva
what purpose did she serve right i mean
i get that she was there as kind of like
the antagonist that was hunting down you
know obi-wan and by extension princess
leia and that kind of a thing right she
was basically the immediate threat
whereas darth vader was kind of the
overall looming threat but looking at it
is kind of like what was the point of
her i wish they'd done a little bit more
with her i do like that she got her kind
of redemption arc that basically she had
like saved the life of luke skywalker
because she didn't want to become darth
vader and then brought luke back to his
uh to his aunt and uncle it was kind of
a funny thing this this you know i was
when i was watching the episode that
statement by baru when she was like no
like we are enough to save luke skyward
but you know were enough and i was
sitting there thinking i was like are
you though because like in episode four
you get turned into crispy critters so
maybe you're a little off with that
statement you know i mean they offered a
great distraction but like as we know
with with with omburu right and uncle
owen they don't make it man right they
get fried they get they get they get
charred so you know like it's it was
kind of a funny little statement there i
don't know if that was designed to be
ironic but i was like
you know
you don't quite make it folks but back
to riva you know i overall
i wish they'd done a little bit more
with her having said that i would like
to see more of her story i don't know if
i would watch like a full-on series
about her but i would love it if they
like transferred her to like maybe
comics or something along those lines
and just kind of told her story about
how she survived in comics because i'm
very curious about that i'm very curious
about the story of riva you know to see
like how she went from the youngling
that survived order 66 and the jedi
purge to everything that that transpired
over that that point in time and
honestly the benefit of doing it in a
comic book form is you'll get these kind
of moments right where like darth vader
will be keeping an eye on her right if
he'll be asking the inquisitor like
what's going on with riva and the
inquisitor is like everything is
proceeding as planned lord vader and
he's like yes i will find obi-wan kenobi
soon you know that kind of a thing it'd
be cool you know i would i would love to
see that but again you know it there's a
few things that stuck out to me as a
little bit strange but all in all i
thought it was a great show i had a
great time watching it i know they had
it listed as the season finale instead
of the series finale so i assume they're
gonna go with the season two to be
honest i think they're gonna gauge the
show they're just gonna gauge the
viewership of the show they're gonna
look at audience retention see how much
of the show people were watching things
like that and then ask the question is
it worth going through with a second
season i think the beauty of the way
this season ended is they could just
call it a day they could just wrap it up
here they could never do a second season
and then we just go directly into what's
basically episode four and and that's it
it's cool because a lot of the things
that we would that that happen in
episode four
make sense based on what we've seen
right like in episode four darth vader
tells everyone kenobi the last time we
met i was but the learner and you were
the master and this one in in at the end
of or at least in this fight and obi-wan
kenobi like he refers to him as master
so he still sees him as a master even if
only kind of a mocking way he still
doesn't necessarily see himself on on
the same level as obi-wan at least in
title you know but it carries over if
you guys understand what i'm saying so a
lot of those threads just connect right
a lot of those things just kind of allow
us to segue directly into so for which i
think is cool honestly i don't know what
they would really do with uh with with
season two what i would really want to
see is i would want to see a tv series
focused on darth vader where they bring
back
if it's not in continuity they bring
back the whole like continuing purge of
the jedi following order 66 were vaders
traveling across the galaxy and hunting
down various jedi and destroying them
the truth here is i would love to see
that done and basically there could be a
kind of overarching plot i don't know
what that overworking plot would be it'd
likely be a character plot for darth
vader but i would like to see like each
individual episode it's him tracking
down a jedi right he kills a different
jedi in each episode but it serves as
part of the larger plot that's going on
with darth vader himself nonetheless you
know the show was great i had a i had a
great time watching it it was an
absolute blast thought it was cool would
i go back and like watch it again of my
own accord
probably not and that's not really a
shot against the show it's just it was
cool and it was fun
i don't know if i'd really go back and
just see it again i don't really have
the drive to do so but then again i'm
more of like a marvel comics fan i'm not
a super hardcore star wars fan so for
those of you guys out there who are
super hardcore star wars fans let me
know what you all think i'm not gonna
lie i am kind of waiting for the replies
where people are like i hate reva
because she was just so emotional and
she was reckless which was okay when it
was anakin but it's not okay because
it's her you know i i'm i'm waiting i'm
waiting for that
i think it's gonna be funny but uh but
for real for true though right like give
me your opinions on the show let me know
what you all think but with that being
said we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace